hey everyone it's benefits of a G from G
tracker and in this video we're going to
go over um making unfinished potions uh
see how much I can make in 1 hour but
before we do why don't we go over and
see who our winners are for last week's
video all right so previously in the
last video I said I was going to use a
random number generator to see who was
who won um out of the comments but I
noticed some of you guys commented more
than once
and and even know you commented more
than once I'm only going to count the
comments where you had your RuneScape
name and this is going to let me know if
you had more than one comment so if if I
if I pick a winner and it shows that
there's more than one comment I'm going
to have to go back and see if they tried
entering the username twice um to try
and see if they were going to you know
boost their chances of winning in which
case you know I'd have to disqualify
them cuz that's cheating um but other
than that let's go ahead and load our
video here and see who the winner is
okay so we have our old school RuneScape
flipping merching cleaning hers for a
profit and there was about 52
comments okay so let's randomly pick a
winner X jigs z4w gaming RuneScape name
Jiggy ZW I never use in real life money
to pay membership and I'm already
starting from free tol and now I'm a
payto playay flipping every day using G
tracker Etc and paying my bonds every
two weeks a free Bond would let me flip
more cheers well Isa you are about
to win yourself a bond so you won't have
to worry about playing freeo play
anymore now let me just take a
screenshot of this
so I can make sure um so I can go back
to this and make sure that I can add you
correctly in the game and then we're
going to go ahead and pick our second
winner
Duncan M RuneScape
name hius I hope I said that right and
you just got premium congratulations and
you just won yourself in Bond as well so
I'm going to take this screenshot as
well and why don't we go ahead and add
these players in game and see if we can
get them their
bonds Okay so so let's go ahead and add
these winner here okay so it's Jiggy Z
with a z let's go ahead and add
them
Jiggy
saw jigy
saw okay they're not online right now
but let's let's make sure that's
correct um chiy Z yeah that's right so
um they're not on right now but I'll go
ahead and try and a couple of hours or
maybe tomorrow um and if you're watching
this Jiggy all you know make sure you
comment in game or you know um try and
talk to me in Discord uh so you can try
get your bond um so congratulations and
let's go ahead and try adding the other
player to see if we can get them
[Music]
here
okay and
hius that's going to be a little bit
weird
to hotus
is that
correct
H
does that looks right
okay oh oh
hello no not lifelines you're not the
winner hellos
sir how are you today
oh no let's not let's not say how are
you congrat congrat
congrats
you have
entered
contest amongst your
peers and have come
out have come out as the winner
come claim your bond good
sir all right so we're just going to
wait on him to see you know when he can
response and we're just going to wait on
him oh my
God I love the
action that's
perfect ha care
to meet me and
lumbridge
oh hello there
congrats un
winning thank you for
playing and supporting our Channel
thank
you
enjoy he doesn't know what to
say go enjoy that good sir and he's off
all right now guess the other guy's not
on right now so we'll just go have to
wait for another time to give the other
guy a good time all right guys so this
is what your unfinished potion is going
to look like and you can find this tool
under moneymaking and it's going to be
under her Profit just like um where we
had the clean herbs in the last video
and with this tool um you're going to be
given different options up here at the
top um Narda is a city in the desert um
where there's an
NPC who will either clean the herbs for
you or make unfinished potions for you
um depending upon whether or not you
completed the desert Diaries
and then also make the potions into a
foros for free and you guys can look at
that at RS Wei um at a later time if you
guys want to but for this um you can
combine any of the options so if you
want to buy Grammy herbs and then find
out how much you would make by going to
Narda uh the city to use that NPC to
make a potion for you it'll tell you how
much you could expect to make on any
given any any um any one of these
potions um so if I wanted to buy clean
herbs and I go to the city it'll give me
that option so it's telling me right now
that I'm going to make more by buying
the the grimy ones as opposed to the
clean ones but I don't have any of the
Diaries done and I don't feel like
traveling to go make these potions or do
anything else I just want to sit at the
Grand exchange buy Grammy herbs maybe
level up a little bit and then make
these UNF finished
potions also while making as much money
as I possibly
can okay and just like all the other
tools you can mess with this table here
to you know find out which is the lowest
cost potion to the highest cost potion
as well as the you know the her price
and then the approximate
profit um but one thing that you'll
notice with this table is it doesn't
have the trading volume for any of the
the herbs so um if if you click on one
of these um links here it'll take you to
that item specific page and it'll show
you the buying and selling quantity of
that item
now one thing you might want to pay
attention to I mean it'll be pretty
apparent um when you're looking at this
is the buy sell ratio now the Buy sale
ratio is going to tell you whether or
not um there's more people buying this
item as opposed to selling it and right
now it's showing a positive um it's
showing it as a positive number and it's
green which means that there's more
people buying this item than there is
selling it and if I go down here um
there's also the price graph but if I
look at the the trading volume graph
it's going to show me that pretty much
all the time there's a lot more people
buying this item than there is selling
it
so naturally I should think that this
should be pretty easy to sell you know
there's always going to be a demand and
shouldn't be too hard for me to get this
off my hands so I shouldn't be too
worried
now now this one looks like the highest
profit um but I'm just going to go ahead
and click on other potions to see you
know how they compare so I've clicked on
I've clicked on this one and the buying
sell ratio is a lot bigger for this
there's a whole lot more people buying
this than there is selling it um and if
you look down here it's pretty apparent
but one thing that comes to mind is that
the quantity is a whole lot smaller so
even though there's more people buying
this um there's only you know doesn't go
above 200,000 as opposed to the other
potion you know was it was reaching up
to 800,000 at any point time even even
up to almost a million
um so that's something to pay atten to
and there's also the RAR potion um if
you want to click on that and then again
Rio is positive so it's telling me that
you know this should be pretty easy to
get off my hands and if I go down to the
price graph it'll show me it's been
pretty stable for the past month hasn't
really changed all that much and again
there's a lot more people buying this
than they're selling it so that's that's
telling me that again this should not
this shouldn't trouble me whatsoever um
trying to make these unfinished potions
and then there'll just be matter of you
know making the potion that I want has
the most profit as well as um making an
unfinished potion that I can make given
my herblore level okay um so yeah
there's that you know you just mess with
the um the tool up here to you know com
combine you know which or whichever you
want to do
um so yeah and then let's get right back
into the video where I'm going to spend
one hour seeing how much I can make
using this
tool all right guys so before I get
started um the first thing I notice is
to clean the herb that showed the
highest profit I would need level 55
that's a little bit unfortunate um but
maybe you guys can find out at the end
of this um how much you would make um
depending on your level if you can make
this potion
um you know good for you maybe you'll
make way more than I will um so see as I
can't clean that let's look at what's
next lowest so I can
clean avento so let's see where that off
okay
so um so looks like that that would be
the next best thing to clean and make um
so that's not too bad um but it it is a
pretty it is a pretty large gap um so
maybe you guys can figure out at the end
of this how much you would make um and
keep in mind that these prices are
always changing so just because I'm
cleaning this and I'm making this um and
I'm saying that this is making more at
the current time um these pric are
always changing so you should always
make sure to check um with this tool to
make sure whatever you're making is
making the most profit or make we're
making sure that um you're not losing
money by making something that um that's
making less than something else and I'm
going to start with 240k because with
the last video we ended at that's the
amount that we ended at and I thought
I'd just make it Easy by starting at um
an even number so we're going to start
making these type of potions and I
already have um a timer here set so it's
going to count down um an hour for me so
I'm just going to go ahead and clear
that and as soon as I start this or we
start the video and um I'll see you guys
at the end this
down
[Music]
I'm
okay guys so um there's only 36 seconds
left so I'm going to go ahead and stop
the clock and I'm not going to buy
another batch in 30 seconds
um so why don't we see how much we made
in 1 hour
all right let's go ahead and sell
these oops these
up put 30 let's try yeah 3900 I've been
selling them for that the whole
time instantly sold okay so we ended up
um at the very
end
with 8
7260 okay so let's go ahead and use our
calculator here so we started with so
640 minus
240k
240k okay so we
made
[Music]
636,000 a potion
I might have made more I'm not sure and
with the tool earlier we were seeing we
were we were able to make more um with
this herb which we couldn't even clean
and you know we might have been able to
break maybe a million per hour um I'm
pretty slow at this probably like the
slowest person to you know uh train
herblore but I'd say that's a pretty
good you know it's a pretty good profit
per hour especially given that it's
herblore it's it's known for losing
money so when you combine cleaning herbs
and making unfinished potions it's a
pretty good profit per hour um you know
there's already quite a bit um of
methods out there for people who with a
lowle skill that you know make something
like that like I know with magic if you
want to um make some
orbs um Earth orbs or whatever like that
it makes a similar amount of money but
you know if you want to go for 99 herb
blower it kind of take forever cleaning
the herbs but in the very end you would
probably make a lot of money um so
there's that um
so um so yeah um thank you guys so much
for watching um I'm going to go ahead
and log into my other account uh my main
to see if uh the other guy our winner um
is logged in so see you guys in a
bit okay so unfortunately uh one of our
winners hasn't logged in yet um Jiggy
all hasn't logged in um so if you're
watching this jiga um try and you know
contact me add me in game my name is a
wild cow um or you can find us in
Discord um I'll leave a link in the
description um so you can go ahead and
find us on our Discord Channel um and my
name on here is benefits of a cow uh you
can either PM me or you can um notify me
here in chat so if you wanted to notify
me you would just type in benefits of
cow so you just type at benefits and it
would come up as the first one if you
wanted to type anyone else's name uh
like James uh James is the owner of the
website um he's like he's the developer
um he's always adding new things to that
so uh that's how you'd contact me um
just so you guys can see what it would
look like when you ping me um it'll
highlight uh my name into the chat um
and then I'll know so yeah Jig Is
All um so thank you guys so much for you
know your support uh uh watching ing the
video all the support um you know with
the last video you guys it was a whole
lot more uh reaction to the last video
than I than I ever expected and you know
we really appreciate that um you know
the support is unreal um you guys so far
you guys have been loving the site um
you guys have been have said nothing but
great things um and also um some of you
guys have been asking about a clan chat
um where you guys can talk to other
like-minded individuals uh merchants
and um I want to direct you guys to
flipping osrs um he's also a YouTuber um
he makes uh merching videos as well and
we actually have a video guide on our
website where we actually have some of
his videos we highlight some of his
videos that we like the most for you
guys to watch in case you guys don't
have uh you guys don't know um so yeah
this is the clan chat um for you guys to
join if you guys ever want to join any
like-minded individuals individuals So
yeah thank you guys so much um be sure
to leave a like down below comment and
subscribe and see you guys till next
time
[Music]